et du coup j'ai un petit cadeau pour
vous je vais j'ai amené le mien perso
ici oui qu'est dieu tu crois bien je te
monte mais après tu et à toi à des mots
c'est 10 minutes tous les matins peu de
chez vous tranquillement hop pendant les
infos sur itélé bim taqwa la première
fois on sait jamais comment le faire si
peux me permettre de t d tu te prends
bien par le bien par le haut allez n'ai
pas peur tu m'attaques les tristes
[Applaudissements]
tu peux le faire des différentes
positions comme tapie le bois mais
l'accident
c'est pas ça c'est comme ça marchait
bien je commence vraiment à prendre du
muscle d'or est pas bon vous l'avez
essayé en version tu peux comme ça bam
bam bam ok ils pas autant me tous mes
trucs mais bon mathieu baber